if you believe in the modern idea of
peace you might be an idiot war huh good
god y'all what's it good for
actually a lot but what about giving
peace a chance
all right we've all heard the slogans
we've seen the signs and we've all heard
the crappy overly hyped songs imagine oh
the people the funny thing about all of
these anti-war celebrities is that they
don't see the irony and getting to spout
their message of wanting peace only
because there are American GIs fighting
overseas against the very people who
don't imagine oh the people
yeah sharlinda Chiron autograph security
huh what piece is a two-way street and
what is the other guy doesn't want peace
what if he's more keen on blowing crap
up what then mr. Lennon okay now I know
what some of you are thinking Stephan
pieces to a noble idea and what have you
got against the great John Lennon okay
Hey
he was an egomaniacal pipsqueak who was
possibly the biggest hypocrite to have
ever walked the face of the planet
imagine no posessions
like my Rolls Royce an Upper West Side
penthouse he also cheated on his wife
repeatedly and abused his son and I
don't like that and be the ultimate goal
of the peace movement is to destroy the
idea of right and wrong which is of
course the reason that the
anti-christian message has been its
fulcrum since the movements inception
believe it or not the whole Christians
and Jews of the cause of all wars card
wasn't introduced by Bill Maher or John
Lennon but by Nero and 54 ad you mean
I'm not as original as I thought I was
now see Nero was an awful person who was
in a constant lookout for scapegoats and
you guessed it she chose the Christians
now he had awful things to them most
notably he crucified the Apostle Peter
on an upside-down cross in the shape of
a V the symbol used to represent this
atrocity was known as the sign of the
broken Christians or Nero's cross or as
we know it today the peace symbol yes
folks the peace symbol has a long and
rich anti-christian history having been
used by the Bolsheviks painting it on
the churches they'd successfully managed
to close all the way to Hitler's SS
brigades now see the problem with the
liberal secularists ideal of peace is
that it only exists in a world where
right and wrong don't once you blur
those lines enough everything becomes
subjective you could just as easily
blame the attacks of 9/11 on the United
States as you would in a Taliban there's
no villain or a good guy or bad guy cuz
that's just simple-minded it was just a
sad inability
for two parties to come to an agreement
what give peace of chumps you do realize
you getting shot right well I don't want
to get shot what do you think is a
modern idea of peace a noble one how
about war is it ever the answer just
violence ever solve problems let me know
I would argue that violence is
oftentimes the answer violence stopped
Nazi Germany ended Stalin's reign
liberated a country free the slaves took
out Saddam Hussein and manages to fix
every remote control I've ever owned
very good what will he do next